let's say I'm in a conversation with
someone and I feel that triggered
feeling something comes up in me I will
go okay I feel that I'll acknowledge it
in myself I hear you I notice and that
helps my body so much even if I just
cognitively I'm like oh information just
happened Ellen didn't do anything even
if you did even if you said a really
jerky thing yeah still the way I
perceive that is mine then I'll go and
sort of unpack this okay what was really
happening she said this and I felt this
how do I know well I felt this feeling
inside of me and I'll sometimes ask
myself the question okay well when else
have I felt this feeling I'm looking for
the proof that came way before this
conversation to say oh I felt this
before this isn't new listen if you can
trigger something in me that means
there's something there I always use the
same example and I know it's silly but I
say if you were to say to me you're a
purple alien
can't believe you
perfect I'd be like are you okay because
listen I know like I'm not a purple
alien you cannot convince me otherwise
I'm sorry I love you but no I would be
very confused because that doesn't
resonate with me at all now if you say
Heather you are so needy I'd be like oh
that resonates like I'm so afraid that
you would think that about me but that's
mine is it true that I'm needy I don't
know is it I gotta check in with myself
where is that coming from why does that
hurt me so bad why did that scare me so
much that you would say that about me
Heather McKean is a best-selling author
International speaker and founder of the
Mind change method she's a Pioneer and
leading expert in the Neurology of
trauma chronic illness and disease and
has helped Empower thousands of people
to take their health and happiness back
into their own hands this is the second
time I've had on Heather the first time
was about a year ago with her husband
Kent where they unpacked what the Mind
change method is and their own personal
stories of healing in this episode which
I'm very excited about we peel back
another layer with practical mindset
tools that can help heal your emotional
trauma which plays out in your
day-to-day life the mind and the stories
that it holds have one of the most
powerful impacts on our overall health
and well-being we are inevitably shaped
by our own personal experiences genetic
predispositions ancestry and programming
yet few people realize the connection
between your subconscious mind and your
emotional and even physical health we
get into all that today and more
including daily tools to rewire your
brain during times of stress and worry
and how your triggers and emotional
reactions are reminders of what still
needs to be healed if you could do me a
favor I would love it if you're
listening to this to hit subscribe on
Apple podcast and give the Ellen Fisher
podcast a review or if you're watching
on YouTube to give this video a thumbs
up and click the Subscribe button on
this channel all your interactions help
a ton to keep this channel thriving so
thank you for being here and I hope you
enjoyed this conversation okay folks we
are back here to talk about the power of
the mind again with none other than one
of my closest friends Heather McKean
thank you so much for being here and to
get into this can you just give us a
brief overview to briefly unpack the
power of the mind and the difference
between what we're going to talk about
today versus like positive affirmations
yes okay great so positive affirmations
are amazing
but if what happens and this is just the
way that the brain works so the way that
the brain works is it will our belief
systems and what we output like in our
behaviors in our really just kind of
autopilot way which we're on most of the
time is this sort of autopilot way of
being comes from what we hold in the
belief systems that we hold in our mind
which is really built from memories and
experiences
so we can affirm things and we do affirm
things all the time so through
confirmation bias through the part of
the brain that we talked about last time
and in the book the reticular activating
system it's like we're set for constant
affirmation but what we're affirming is
what we already know so a lot of times
what people are trying to do is they're
trying to put like a positive
affirmation say something over and over
and over and over again in an effort to
not do something or not be a certain way
or not think a certain thing or not
believe a certain thing and so that's
where we get into something that's a bit
tricky when we're dealing with really
the way that the brain works which is
you're going to Output which is the mo
which the things that are mostly input
so we are affirming and if you think
like let's take a positive affirmation
that you may want like I'm healthy and
Wealthy let's take that one right yeah
if what happens in your mind when you
speak out loud I'm healthy and wealthy
if your mind immediately goes yeah but
I'm not but I'm broke but I I have this
problem and this thing even if it's that
thought that comes up
words are so powerful So speaking
something is very powerful but what your
brain does with it after you speak it is
actually even more powerful okay so what
happens then so then you're actually
affirming those negative beliefs those
negative thoughts so you may speak this
one thing out loud but if the proof that
you have in your mind if you're true
true is that you're not that you're just
sick that you're you know whatever all
the different horrible things we say
about ourselves right which we shouldn't
but we do that really comes from our
belief system
so a lot of times what we're trying to
do and listen I get it we're any tools
we can use to help improve our life I
understand the appeal of it
but let's supercharge it let's actually
make it work so if in my mind I'm
thinking
okay no actually I'm broke and I'm sick
and I'm these things and that's my
reality that's what I want to go in and
work with so it's still information
right it's still I'm going to say this
positive affirmation and in my mind I'm
in a list now all the ways that that's
not true that's what I want to go after
okay so how do you do that what is the
Mind change method what makes it
different than positive affirmations
okay great so we and I will say this is
really basic information once you know
it but it is a bit counterintuitive
because we have outsourced so much of
our happiness our health our beliefs
outside of us so it it people will
sometimes they can it really be that
simple
it can be that simple when we know the
way the brain works and really the
reason this feels like new information
is neuroscience is a very young science
we didn't have the imaging technology to
image the brain to watch the way the
brain worked we didn't really understand
the brain at all so and now with Quantum
science and everything we're starting to
understand our energy fields and the
energy of our brain and our heart and
our gut so really there's just it's
exciting it's so exciting but it's kind
of the information that we've just
gotten so far away from so what do you
do with this
how do you know that you are sick that
you are broke whatever other belief
systems that we're going to to have come
up in
um opposition to what we would call the
positive affirmation
that's where in one sense the gold is
because when I know that stuff and I go
okay well how do I know that I'm sick
and I'm probably going to go into well
maybe for me like if your audience knows
me by now um they know I used to use do
tons of really significant diseases and
if you would have asked me in the midst
of all of that how do you know you're
sick
probably would have taken offense to it
actually right because I'm like it was
my identity I wasn't just
sick having illnesses and diseases I was
those things yeah so people will notice
that you said I did these illnesses yes
can you explain that before you keep
going yes
um what I realized and this was through
all of the different research that I've
done and the different modalities that
I've researched and become certified in
so this didn't come just uh like basic
easy information what I realized let's
say to do depression
um the languaging we usually use in our
societies that you have depression and
it's actually kind of offensive it might
be offensive for some people for you to
even say that it's a choice that you're
doing it right and I think that's where
I would maybe do a little bit more
definition yeah because Choice makes it
sound like I sat here and had I picked
no depression depression let me pick
depression that was the choice I made
and I think that's where people get
offended or triggered is because then
what what you hear me saying is so
you're saying I chose to be depressed
yeah when really just by saying the word
I'm doing it or you're doing it doesn't
actually mean that you're choosing it
exactly consciously consciously and
remember
95 of what we do think believe the
emotions that we have the reactions that
we have are subconscious so even that
even to be triggered by or to be
offended by me saying that someone's
doing something is belief systems even
that is like wait why is that happening
inside of me she just put a couple words
together and made me feel something
inside and that's and I would say
honestly Ellen the
if I could say the biggest thing about
mind change
is empowerment where we place our power
and if we give depression the power or
the diagnosis the power or even an SSRI
or a medication the power this is going
to make me well
then we're what I say is we're
Outsourcing power
and I believe that is really that's the
end-all be-all problem is how often
we've outsourced our power our health
our beliefs our way of being right if
you can say something that can make me
fall apart inside
and like might make my my heart rate
increase make my the anger boil up make
me want to maybe hurt you
or lash out or lash out which is like
very relational like a lot of times it's
like you've made me this way yes like
you're in an argument it's like it's not
my fault I'm yelling you said this and
now I'm yelling because you upset me
hurt my feelings angered me whatever
yeah then you're Outsourcing the powder
yes like it's they're the one who made
you do it right which means I just gave
you the power to control my inner
resources
to and it's just here's the truth you
don't have that power you don't unless I
give it to you
and even then even though I'm sort of
giving you the power you don't actually
have the power to do anything to me that
is choice
we want to talk about choice that is
Choice like how you react to something
how I react to something and uh Victor
Frankel who wrote man search for meaning
I think that's what it's called anyway I
love it so much and I talk about it so
much and I don't have the name down but
he was a holocaust Survivor and one of
the biggest points I took away from that
book I mean it's a beautiful book and
it's amazing but was he he
chose his experience in those
concentration camps that's really heavy
like that gets to like a whole other
level because it's one thing if you were
talking about like a light argument you
know it's another to be talking about
experiencing the Holocaust right and and
making the choice and what he did though
and this is what I think is
so powerful
he really
owned that they can't make me feel
anything they can't take away me they
can put me in here and they can take
they can reserve things from me but you
can't make me think I'm this or feel
this way and that's how he retained his
autonomy his sovereignty his mind and I
really think his life if you really
listen to the way that he explains that
I really think that choice saved his
life that's amazing I need to read that
book it's amazing and I think that that
is just and I you know given his
experience for him to say that it may be
easier for someone to hear it from him
who had very
undeniable Horrors where someone could
look at me and say you know which people
don't know my history and my story and I
think it doesn't really matter but I had
my fair share of what we would call Big
T trauma growing up but still I think
that that's for all of us
biggest thing is power where we take
that power if I'm giving it to a
diagnosis if I'm saying
I have depression
and and then it just is like I just got
it somewhere
so I need to find a reason that I have
it a place that I got it oh okay so well
then it's genetics maybe it's hormones
maybe it's you know some sort of
chemical imbalance which is what I was
told which is not true scientifically
not true to have a chemical imbalance
that would lead you to having depression
now not like they took blood and then oh
we found a chemical imbalance that is
that it doesn't happen so that doesn't
work it doesn't work that way it doesn't
happen that way that's a common like
thing you hear very common thing that
you hear and and I really do believe I'm
not going to vilify doctors I think
doctors are amazing people I work with a
lot of doctors actually and
um they say that they got into this to
help people they're just as frustrated
as everyone else because if you really
sit and talk to doctors who got into
this because they want to help people
they love people they care they are just
as frustrated they're
they feel in fact they're they feel
traumatized it's what we call tertiary
trauma where people who are trying to
help people
become traumatized themselves because
they realize like what I'm doing is not
helping and you hear a terrible story
after terrible story after terrible
story and they're trying they're giving
try this drug and try this thing and try
this therapy and try this and it's not
working and they're hurting for people
and so they end up taking that on
themselves that makes a lot of sense
because the medical system can help and
save lives it saves lives every day
helps so many people in many ways but it
does fall short when it comes to many
things in regards to the human body's
Health it's like maintaining sickness as
opposed to thriving reversing healing
yes so now you're you're getting there
keep going as to like this topic of like
why I have it versus doing it okay
so if you really research depression
we'll take we'll just use that one and
I've talked about it before but a lot of
stuff has to happen
to be able to produce what we would call
what we would call the the diagnosis of
depression for you to have textbook
depression your body has to do an
enormous amount of things
it takes time to do it you don't
contrary to what some people may feel
you don't wake up with clinical
depression one day yeah the day before
you were fine and then I woke up and we
we sort of think of it almost like a
virus or a disease or something like
that like I contracted it oh my gosh
yeah it's very subconscious but it is
kind of the way it's spoken about yes
and I will say it's so good that you
said that it is subconscious what we
have to understand that we've been
indoctrinated
we it it doesn't make sense for us to
come out and say these different things
yeah especially because we're in a
culture right now that wants to
normalize
uh mental health problems
right and not make make people feel
judged oh I'm totally for that yeah
judgment is never going to help anybody
right but it isn't going to heal anybody
either yeah to really just keep saying
like this is my issue and I'm never
going to get better the Mind goes okay
well we obviously have an investment in
never getting better and if we Outsource
to to medications to pills which I'm
have been a great bridge for people so I
don't want to vilify that either right
but it's not what we want to do long
term because long term ssris actually
make their being balances in our brain
because if you so here's the thing with
depression
what you have to do to do depression and
I say do because it action is required
to do it you can't just be lying in bed
and all of a sudden it's like some
random thing just comes and it gets you
now you got it they have it right so if
you are and and let me just stop here to
say
if this is triggery
the reason that it's triggery is because
of guilt shame blame that's why Always
it's always going to be about that and
we live in a culture that thrives on
guilt shame and blame so what do you
mean by that explain a little more so
what people automatically do with that
like you've said before is so you're
saying this is my fault no no
not saying we don't talk about fault
yeah fault is a useless conversation as
far as I'm concerned it isn't fault yeah
uh the difference and I go into this in
the book kind of in detail but the
difference between fault and
responsibility and the book is the Mind
change method if you haven't watched the
first episode we did together yes so
that differentiation between fault and
responsibility responsibility is
empowered mm-hmm fault is blame and and
it's disempowering it's victimization
so if people hear from me that oh you're
saying that I'm I'm doing depression
which means it's my fault like I have a
choice in it then they're gonna shut
down automatically and I get that I do
get that so so please hear yeah that is
not what I'm saying
but what if
for very good reason and that's what I
always sort of qualify if anyone's doing
anything
even or what we would consider horrible
things because at this point in my
career I've worked with
lots of different people coming from a
lot of different angles so um
perpetrators even who are finally at a
stage where they want help you know
where they're coming in yeah when you
sit and you listen
and you hear and you put the pieces
together and you take the person as a
whole from the the epigenetics
epigenetics is um ancestry trauma being
passed down in our genes that's the
science of that you look at them from an
epigenetical standpoint you look at what
the the family that they were they came
into remember without the word fault
information and we step back and you say
okay this and then this and then this
and then this
it makes sense right now it doesn't make
it good yeah and for a lot of those
people it helps them so much to
understand why they're doing what
they're doing but just understanding why
it doesn't then change it right but if
we can understand that the power and
often this comes from situations and
beliefs and cultures when we were
children
and it really boils down to we didn't
get our needs met
and again let's not do faults yeah this
is not to be like oh it's your mom's
fault or it's your dad's fault no
however your ancestors no they were
doing the best that they could
I want to tell you about the empowered
pregnancy and birth course that I worked
so hard on these last months and I've
never been more proud of something I've
created and Heather McKean is one of the
contributors in this course this course
is filled with everything I wish I was
told before I came pregnant with my
first child over a decade ago to have an
easier quicker labor and even a
pleasurable birth experience I created
the course with my sister Hannah McNeely
and we have some incredible contributors
in this course including Dr Gemma Newman
who collaborated with us on plant Ford
prenatal nourishment she's an MD who's a
senior partner at a family medical
practice that has worked in many
Specialties including obstetrics
Gynecology and Pediatrics we have Haley
Callahan a donor certified Doula who
collaborated with us on having an
empowered birth for those choosing a
hospital setting we also have an
incredible yoga instructor Michelle
Minch with prenatal yoga classes in
birth meditation and finally Heather
McCain on the Mind change method and how
to rewire your brain for a more
pleasurable and gentle birth experience
which is one of the most powerful parts
of the course in my opinion because
something like Hypno birthing for
example can be really helpful for a lot
of women but for many women like myself
you can say all the positive mantras you
want out loud and envision the birth you
desire but if your subconscious believes
otherwise and tells you uh-uh that's not
what birth feels like I know what the
movie showed me it feels like I know
what my mom and friends say it feels
like I know what my past birth
experiences even felt like then it's not
going to get you very far that's why we
have to rewire our brain and change not
only the conscious mind but also the
subconscious mind and Heather someone
who's helped so many women like myself
achieved the birthday desire shows you
in this course how to do that this
course is centered around becoming
empowered and making informed choices
optimal pregnancy nourishment giving
birth where you feel safest getting back
to birthing wisdom and my favorite part
how to have an easy quick and
pleasurable birth experience it's filled
with how to prepare your mind and body
for conception creating a birth plan
that's right for you we also go into
nutrients of focus healthy foods to
embrace and supporting your body through
movement how to get baby in the optimal
position for birth and the secrets to
avoid tearing how to have an easier
labor guaranteed and the information
that made my last three labors
significantly more pleasurable gentle
quick and easy than my first two we
include everything you need to know
postpartum breastfeeding and more and
there's even a lesson for your partner
if you have one in how they can best
support mama in pregnancy labor birth
and postpartum so you can get access to
the course at ellenfischer.com or click
the link in the show notes and
description box just click the link to
learn more about the course I've never
been more proud and excited about
something I've created birth is
life-changing and I'm really passionate
about sharing all that birth can be
gentle peaceful easy and even pledgeable
I tell a story in the book about
um a girl who was having a really
difficult relationship with her mom and
happened to have tricked telemania hair
pulling and she
pulled very significantly she was to the
point where she had pulled out eyebrows
eyelashes like wow really had a severe
case of trichotillomania and had done
therapy had done all kinds of things and
had not
you know had not gotten any relief from
that so that the book tells the story
that when we started to do sessions
and we got into all of this then we saw
that there was this sort of I don't
think they had gotten to the point where
they were estranged but man her
relationship with her mother was really
strained
and as we Dove deeper into that some
memories came up about how when she was
a little girl when she was I think it
was around eight years old she was in
school what she remembered was her
mother angrily pulling her hair up into
a really tight ponytail every morning
and and what she felt like was her
mother was angry at her and she was
being rough with her head
and so she internalized that feeling
like mom's mad at me there's something
wrong with me I've done something and I
don't know what it is and mom is upset
with me and I'm not good this is the an
eight-year-old right that's what an
eight-year-old does that's what they
think totally
so so now she's in her I think gosh I
don't even remember how old she was 30s
probably at this point
and we start getting into this
and we go through like what could have
been happening with Mom at that time and
she had all these belief systems around
what was going on in mom at the time and
when we realized like did Mom ever say
that no did Mom ever like what gave you
that idea and she realized it was just a
perception
and so we worked through these things
and and here's the thing too about
trauma it isn't just in our minds it
does get stored in our body our
autonomic nervous system then stores
reactions in our body
based on the way our mind is going right
right so at the time she had these very
significant autonomic nervous reactions
in her as a little girl where she got on
her level she remembered being like
frozen or what we would call Fawn
there's fight flight freeze Fawn right
she would just get Frozen and then fun
and not be able to say anything what's
the difference between Frozen and fawn
it's it's
nuanced I would say to Fawn is usually
if someone's fawning they're they're
becoming very pliable they're being
sometimes when you someone freezes they
are still in a almost like a a sort of a
fight reaction but it's they've gone
down to that thing of like fighting
isn't okay I need to just freeze and act
like I'm not alive yeah and so
oftentimes they won't hear they're very
just still
fun is actually going even deeper into
that where they feel so at the mercy of
another person that you can do anything
right got it so in sexual trauma often
we'll have a fond response got it where
people from the outside will be like you
should have you should have fought you
should have done something the nervous
system went no the safest option is to
just do what they say be completely
pliable
and so she had kind of gone we
recognized into these sort of freezer
Fawn responses
so she never spoke up anything she never
said anything she never inquired and so
this is the belief right so we got into
this thing and she said um so what's the
belief that my hair is
ugly my hair is a problem
and I was like okay yeah so think about
that subconsciously that she never
connected those things so she started to
pull her hair out
because and I know this gets crazy but
this is the way our brain works
it was a way to stay connected with Mom
she's having this actual dissociation
from Mom this separation from Mom she
feels like she just can't see eye to eye
with Mom and so but listen we never stop
wanting those relationships with our
parents so we keep using the
maladaptions that we learned as children
and we keep doing that even as adults
and so it was just further separating
her and her mom
we worked through we calmed her nervous
system down we shifted some ways that
her brain held those memories and she
was just like oh my gosh I feel so much
better amazing so then she calls her mom
which I actually don't suggest had she
asked me I probably would have been like
you may want to wait a minute for that
but she didn't and she did and it ended
up beautiful so she called her mom and
she said you know I just worked with I
just did this mind change session and we
got to the point or a memory that I
never even remembered and you were so
awful to me you were so mean with the
way you treated me and pulling my hair
and and like you were so mad at me and
you hated my hair and her mom was like
what are you talking about
like so completely didn't know crazy and
luckily we'd done some work so she
didn't just lash out and feel
invalidated she went ahead and explained
she had found her voice a little bit and
she explained
and she said you when I was this age you
started putting my hair up in these
really horribly tight ponytails and you
were so mad at me when you were doing it
and her mom thought for a second she's
like oh my gosh
that was the age where your best friend
got lice or what we call Uber's here
right yeah and she said and they sent
these notices home that everyone needed
to have their hair up really really
tight and to try to avoid you know the
life spread right and she said I was so
panicked because you had the most
beautiful hair long thick beautiful hair
and her best friend had to have had to
have her head shaved wow and she was
like the trauma her mom felt and the
child felt from having to shave her head
I wanted to make sure that never
happened to you yeah so I put your hair
up as tight as I possibly could and
she's like I was never angry at you I
was afraid wasn't it crazy that is such
a crazy story I remember reading that
that book and it reminds me so much it
brings me back to Parenting and how you
never know what's going to be the thing
the moment that your child remembers yep
and and how they're gonna remember it
how they're going to remember yes how
it's going to be perceived and so it
just reminds me about like open
communication about everything could
only help yeah and I have two teenage
girls now yeah and I it is actually
helping me realize more and more like
um one of my daughters recently
so significantly edited history in her
mind to support the way she was feeling
then yeah that she made this whole story
about what happened it had to do around
her birthday and everything and I was
like oh you believe that's the way it
went down yeah she really believes it it
is not the way that it went down but we
do that even in our adulthood we do
that's why sometimes if you get an
argument with your partner and then you
later look back on it and start talking
about it you both remember it happening
differently like what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do are you gonna know
what the truth is we are we have
Wikipedia brains completely if it
doesn't fit with what we're feeling
right now we edit it it's revisionist
right we'll go in and we will revise it
through pictures through sounds through
ways that we and we will change our
memories right so that's why like talk
therapy can be helpful in certain ways
but it can only get you so far because
it's not actually I think people don't
realize how malleable our brains are and
how much you can truly change
um the way that you feel about
experiences the way that you even saw
those experiences I've done multiple
mind change sessions with Heather and
then later when I go to talk to my
friends about what we worked on I can
almost not even remember what the thing
was like I'm like wait what is it that
happened what did we work on and I can't
even like fully remember how I
originally told the story about the
thing that impacted me in my childhood
or however it's amazing how much it
changes and then it when you go back and
think about it it doesn't raise your
blood pressure it doesn't start to get
you anxious like it did before because
you truly changed the way that you saw
that experience yes and that's power
totally now people get this is where we
are about to step over that line and
people get yeah but because I do believe
we've been so invalidated for because
we're invalidated as children the child
falls down they hurt their knee don't
you don't need to cry don't cry there's
no reason to cry that's how we start to
become invalidated they I tell a story
like had I done that with my daughter
like child
is not what happened yeah that is not
weaponed you know
she would have the where she would have
gone with that immediately is you're not
validating my beliefs my story my
feelings right and that's ultimately it
we create those stories and those things
to validate our own feelings
and when someone else doesn't do that
we're like what what are you doing
that's so wrong so I get that and now
we're just a bunch of adults walking
around looking to be validated because
we didn't get validation as children
so when I say something like you know we
have the choice or that it's something
that we're doing or this changing the
story in our mind puts the power back in
us people like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
you're telling me to change my story but
this is what happened this is my truth
this is what happened to me don't tell
me it didn't happen to me and I get that
I get that
brain the memory doesn't work that way
though the brain doesn't hold memories
exactly the way that they were input it
just doesn't that was one of the most
mind-blowing Parts about learning about
them about like mind changes just the
power of the Mind how over time when you
tell a story you were talking about how
it changes a little bit every time yes
every time Wikipedia man yeah and don't
take my word for it look up Elizabeth
Loftus there are many many I saw uh site
a lot of stuff in my book about where I
learned this there's a lot of research
this isn't made up this isn't just
agenda this is truth yeah the way that
our brain works so then talking back
about power and how we do things if
we're talking about depression even we
have this culture and we have this
romance around what it means we don't
want it to be invalidated
so then I I always try to talk about to
people like okay but what is do you want
to continue to do depression
or even if they want to use to be
depressed
because a lot of stuff has to happen in
your brain to do that
to continue to do that it's actually a
success
to keep being depressed you have to do a
lot of stuff continuously you have to
depress push down neurotransmitter
production of Serotonin oxytocin the
happy feel good chemicals your brain has
to do that it has to be depressing and I
think people just say well that's out of
my control right and I would say you're
right it is because you don't understand
yet how much control you have because
you haven't lived in a world that tells
you that you have lived in a world that
tells you the opposite exactly the
opposite we need our you know government
through politicians we need our religion
through churches and Priests we need our
health through doctors we need and we
just Outsource Outsource Outsource all
the time it's very empowering though to
hear that you do have more power than
you think in all kinds of situations not
just like serious illnesses but
something as simple as going back to
like the argument thing if you if you
realize next time you're in a
disagreement with your partner where
what they say some that triggers you
you're and you feel this heat rising
within you and you want to lash out like
take a pause for a moment and realize
like wait this is my choice this is my
choice to react this way I'm I'm
choosing this right I can I could go the
other way and it's very it's annoying
it's frustrating because then you see it
in yourself and you're like oh because
this is something you said that I love
your triggers and emotional reactions
are reminders of what still needs to be
healed yes so any time that you feel
triggered and you feel that anxiousness
anxiety you want to get mad you're
frustrated it doesn't have to be with
your partner it could be anything
something you see online something
someone else says whatever anything when
you start to feel that anxiety coming up
like if you just pause for a minute a
minute and realize like wait this is my
choice to react to this no one's making
me do this yes and that's actually
ultimate validation
ultimate validation is I whoa whoa I'm
feeling things right now something is
happening inside of my body based on
something you just said yeah why is that
let me let me validate that I'm feeling
feelings yeah I'm having things happen
feeling all the feelings hold on a
second everyone needs to know yes like
let me just pause and I do this now and
it's really that shift from in the book
I call it victim Victor and and I really
qualify around victim because there's a
lot of wording around that and
everything but in in one sense too it's
like hey my body my mind my
neurotransmitters you let me just hold
on you don't get to be up in here unless
I allow it right unless I choose to
allow yeah unless I choose to allow it
so what is it that you said that has got
me all messed up in my own self right
now yeah and something that you just
said about victim versus Victor is
really important I think to preface
because you're right it does it's very
triggery for people with this
conversation but there's a difference
between being a victim to something
versus living in victimhood yes
completely and I really think that
actually does go back to Victor Frankel
and what his point was of oftentimes we
can't help if we are victimized
especially as children being a children
listen a child if anything happened to
you
you were a victim and because we don't
have the that sovereignty yet to to
speak up for ourselves in a lot of ways
right always with children but even as
adults things can happen to us people
can hurt us lash out hurt people tend to
hurt people yeah and it's what we do
with it after that am I going to be
identified as a rape victim as a you
know abused person and we've I've worked
with a lot of women from domestic abuse
and the empowerment that they get when
they step out of that identity doesn't
mean it didn't happen but it doesn't
have to be fear-based anymore it doesn't
have to be you they don't give that
person real estate in their mind anymore
they don't give that person just the
memory of that person access to their
heart rate
access to their gut they don't give them
access anymore no my body my
neurotransmitters my nervous system you
don't get to affect it unless I let you
and I think it sounds like people
listening I'd be like yeah easier said
than done but that is the truth like it
is a lot of work to rewire your brain to
change your mind it takes work and it
does anytime like okay so over the years
I've learned to you know use some of the
tools that I've learned from you
um to do like on my own and I have to
really focus on it like it is it is a
lot of work to like
to shift your mind to shift your mindset
so this is like nothing to invalidate
people's experiences people's the the
victims that have the victimhood how do
you explain that the thing that has
happened to them yes
um
um and you can you can be a victim but
there's a difference between living in
victimhood your whole life versus
being a victim to something we call that
secondary gains when there's something
that someone is getting from the story
so and that's the thing we've got to be
really careful about is and the mind
will do this it won't hold on to
something unless there's benefit
so and someone would think what could
possibly be the benefit from holding on
to the identity of being an abused woman
or whatever but oftentimes there there
is and our mind our subconscious mind
does these interesting things similar to
the client with the triptylinea what it
did how she
um perceived that situation and what she
wanted was this close relationship with
Mom but felt like there was this thing
standing in the way that she couldn't
even give words to
and so that became this thing in the
subconscious mind went ahead and filled
in the gaps with the information she did
have
so what could possibly be the benefit of
that we think let me tell you we don't
do something unless the Mind finds it
beneficial we are really resourceful as
humans so oftentimes people think if I
let go of this story
if I let go of this victimized story
then I set myself up to be a victim
again that's what they think but if I'm
just mad and I'm strong and I'm fighting
then no one will ever do this to me
again now wasn't that part of your story
too it was part of my story yes I was
very had a very hard Edge to me and what
it did unfortunately was it pushed a lot
of people who I loved away you don't get
to just compartmentalize like that I was
in my mind I was either strong and rough
and you don't even don't mess with me
uh or I was completely a victim I was a
complete doormat and you were doing that
for good reason the strong tough rough
because it was like a barrier to what
the abuse that you experienced growing
up yes and that was part of that story I
told myself as a child was you know this
is how I managed that and an even bigger
piece of that story was I really
believed that I had made a decision when
I was 10 years old that the physical
abuse wouldn't hurt me anymore
that like this is the power of the mind
I wouldn't feel it anymore and from my
memory if you were tough enough if I was
if I could toughen up wow and so and I
did I don't remember feeling the abuse
after that
and so and I told myself a further
because I do the mind is that powerful
now did it make it okay that it was
happening is it true that my body wasn't
being attacked or couldn't really feel
it
no that's not a good thing to happen to
somebody's body but my mind blocked it
because it was actually better for me to
block the pain than to feel the pain
because then what I did with it
secondarily was okay if I don't feel
pain I'm gonna take the bulk of the
abuse
because that'll help my brother and my
mom so I would put myself in the the
Limelight you if you will of my
stepfather at the time to be the one
that would take the majority of the
abuse
because I didn't feel it is what I said
yeah and that belief system served me as
a child
it really did it served me
um problem with belief systems though is
you don't get to just shut them off
because you come and become an adult
so as an adult I was very unfeeling yeah
I had a very hard time connecting and
then I had kids
and if you don't have access to emotions
when you have kids or getting married I
didn't have the access to those emotions
because the brain did something with
that if I could feel I could get hurt
right and when I thought I could get
hurt it meant get hurt hurt physically
hurt like destroyed right so my mind
just went okay well we don't feel easy
yep okay so what about for other types
of ailments that are as clear to
understand like this this experience
example you just gave like it's very
clear like it makes complete sense right
like how you got there once it's
explained but what about other types of
ailments that seem very hard to explain
or understand what could be the root
cause because like really you when you
do mind change and brain rewiring you
want to get what's the root cause what's
causing this symptom right yes so can we
can we unpack a few symptoms that you've
helped people with
um that what could potentially be the
root cause for some people if like let's
say they're having a symptom and they
can't figure out they've tried different
like health things the different
lifestyle things and nothing seems to be
helping or maybe they're told they're
always going to have to live with this
and it's incurable quote unquote and I
think what's so special about this
conversation is that it's like a
mind-body spirit approach it's not just
this isn't like you know your whole
Wellness whole body Wellness really
isn't just your mind it's not just the
food you eat it's not just like your
lifestyle it's like everything combined
yes works for your body absolutely yeah
so if we're going to talk about
specifically for the mind today because
obviously that's the topic of this
conversation can we get into a couple
specific common ailments yes just unpack
that okay so maybe the first one would
be like skin issues like eczema
um rosacea acne different things like
that okay
so glad that you transitioned right at
that point because I can tell you then
from my history where I had just said I
didn't feel it but something was still
happening to my body yes
how my body
did communicate to me yes explain that
yeah through illness and disease
that's how so even though I was this
like strong person and just didn't see
myself as weak right
the truth of the matter was I was weak
because I was diseased I had multiple
diseases I was laid up in bed I mean I
had my body was my body was speaking out
what my Consciousness wasn't doing
wasn't admitting that I had been hurt
that I had been abused that a lot of
really hard things had happened to me
and I was invalidating me and I could
talk about it oh yeah I had abuse and I
had this but I wasn't dealing with it it
was still happening and my body was like
this sucks man like yeah this is really
hard can we do something about this so
that's how it spoke up is in disease now
your body speaks to you it's speaking to
you and giving you notifications it
always will it was meant to constantly
ideally we are supposed to be like you
said whole and this was mind-blowing to
me because I got into mind change having
studied some Mind Body Connection stuff
and realizing that ooh a missing piece
for me is the neurobiology I wanted more
science the rest of it felt a little
woo-woo for me so I was like I need
science and that's when I started
studying neurobiology and I was like
whoa this is amazing and in my mind
everything was mind everything was mind
if you wanted to change anything it was
in your mind right and not like in your
head but from your mind you change the
memories you change the way you hold
it'll change the things in your body
then as I was researching further
a little piece hit me where the the
heart in in birth and development right
I started doing a lot of birth stuff
work through you thank you and um I
happen to be reading something I believe
around my research around birth
and I was like oh my gosh the heart
beats before the brain is developed
I was like
what you're like whoa wait a second I'm
like if everything comes from the brain
the heart shouldn't be able to beat
right it's all connected it's not like
just one thing it's all connected yeah
so now my practice has sort of shifted
now we do the three brain approach
interesting brain brain heart brain gut
brain let me tell you if any one of
those things is off you're going to have
dis-ease somewhere in your life and in
your body and in your mind
it's going to happen so we take a really
different approach I was like I need
more training I need more learning I
need this approach and that approach so
because we want to have that Collective
way of healing so let's take something
like uh you said skin disease skin
disorders yeah conditions like um eczema
acne and rosacea I tell a lot of people
these days that my job is to be a
translator but I'm actually just a
translator I translate what the body is
trying to tell you and and it doesn't
speak the same language so in it speaks
really in the language of
um kinesthetic like if I can feel it if
it's happening inside of my body right
that's the way the body speaks and we've
just not been trained to listen to that
we just don't live in a culture where
that's the case now it hasn't always
been that way back way back at the dawn
of uh medicine which is Hippocrates
he says it's my favorite quote by him
it's better to know the kind of person
that has the disease than the kind of
disease the person has
he that is really father of medicine
yeah I've never heard that before and
it's in the Hippocratic Oath when they
when the young Med students take the
Hippocratic Oath there's so much in
there I feel like we've lost about so
much we like that's not anywhere to be
found in modern medicine no but it was
at the dawn of medicine where they said
if your body is doing something that
where where it's happening what what
it's doing tells us what we need to know
and that goes to that root cause that's
where the birth of functional medicine
the rebirth it's really a rebirth of
functional medicine where people were
like this is not working what we're
doing you need to get to the root of it
and I think that was a good step but now
they're still when it's the food and
it's the this and it's the that where
and that has an impact yeah it does have
an impact but you got to go even deeper
than that listen to what the body is
saying it's not just that alone that's
like like the approach of like the whole
body Wellness approach yes okay so let's
take it from
uh and and how did I learn this
information first of all had I did a lot
of study and let me find the earliest
references of what if this part of the
body is there's something going on with
this part of the body what does it mean
so you can look in Chinese medicine
they've had this for a long long time
ayurvedic so you know a middle eastern
kind of approaches this isn't new it's
old and we need to get back into it
right so lots of stuff my first people
that I looked at were Louise Hay
love Louise Hay brilliant woman
um who started to notice and she did a
lot of that groundwork and she could say
it was a bit basic if you've got a
problem in your head it's probably this
if you've got a problem in your elbow
it's probably this and it's kind of one
wordy and maybe little phrases and stuff
like that but it was so helpful for me
in the beginning wow to start to learn
the the
just even what parts of the body
represent it as a whole maybe an emotion
she was really good at hooking emotion
into particular parts of our body yeah
so
she was the first
um in a Seagal secret language of
language of your body was my second
where I she got into it a little bit
deeper and I was like this is brilliant
and then I was like I need more and so I
just started anything I could find from
as far back as I could read having read
translations and everything basically
like what it could be yes yes for what
it and here's the beautiful part of it
it's the same you can read something
from 3 000 years ago
that they said this means this no way
and Louise Hay is saying the same thing
here in the 1900s you know or whatever
she she died not that long ago but she
was doing this in the 70s so you know
I'm like it's real like this is people
are making this stuff up and now at this
point when I've worked with thousands
and thousands of clients when I say when
you tell me we've got something going on
and I'm like okay here are some of the
ways that your body could be speaking to
you tell me what resonates
99 of the time people were like what the
heck yeah no it's real it's legit real
there's there have been times where I'm
like okay what what is going on here or
maybe I'm just like mentioning something
and you're like hey I looked this up it
could be this I'm like oh yeah so I've
been keeping notes
um I did it on myself first because
I was Queen of the you know doing all
the diseases and everything so I needed
to know what was my body saying and so
that's the first thing that I did was I
wrote every single condition that I had
been diagnosed with and any information
I could find and I started to
cross-reference and go oh my gosh here
are the themes in my life
so victimization was a big theme for me
disempowerment was a big theme for me
um feeling like I needed to protect
myself you know such big themes like I
always had to do it all on my own and my
body was saying this in all these
different ways
and the Beautiful Thing and frustrating
thing about the body is if you don't
listen to the first message
it UPS the volume
and that's where we see a progression
especially in chronic illness you will
rarely meet someone who's just doing one
chronic illness
and at this point I can kind of tell
people on where they're at on their
trajectory like you keep on this path I
can write down your next three diagnoses
because it's you've seen it so much I've
seen it so much and also by you telling
me what you have currently we can say I
can I notice patterns and I'm like okay
if you don't deal with this stuff here's
gonna be your next three ways that your
body speaks up don't you wish that this
type of information was worked with
modern medicine to like be the optimal
okay well some doctors are finally doing
this like a lot I've got a number of
clients who are medical doctors and
um this has been so helpful for them
first of all we had to clear their some
of their stuff you know they're like I
just need help from me at this point and
psychiatrists and you know a lot of
people in the field of helping people
yeah they are they're taking on the
burden yes and it's a collective grown
because there's just hardly anything is
working right so you talk to anyone
who's in the mental health field almost
anyone there's beautiful people coming
out now you know that are saying things
not that there are more beautiful people
before but we just didn't have the same
information that we we really needed
they will say what we're doing is not
working
it's an epidemic it's managing it's
managing and it's actually making things
worse oh my gosh yes like the time like
with uh people in my life who you see a
symptom and then there's a drug and then
the drug causes this ailment and then
there's another drug for that one and
that causes that one it's it's just
heartbreaking I was there too so when
you are so desperate you are so
desperate for some sort of relief and
you've got a an authority figure who you
have put so much hope into and so much
please help me please rescue me and they
say this is going to help you take it it
doesn't even matter the side effects
that are listed you take it right and
oftentimes people will feel better
initially and we call that the placebo
effect and the placebo effect is not a
bad thing it's actually a really good
thing but it frustrates scientists but
it really talks about the power of the
mind yeah the placebo effect is
essentially the mind it is and it's
great it works it works it works so well
it really he messes up science right you
know and and the medical field because
they can't they can't manage that okay
so let's get back into the specific
ailments like first let's start with
skin conditions okay
so and this is kind of the angle that we
take is the outward what is skin skin is
a protective layer right so if we kind
of think about it that way so
metaphorically it really protects us
from what we let in and what we you know
what we keep in what we let in and
everything like that so now if you want
to talk about acne we've got a
completely different that's a different
voice or a different
um message than let's say rosacea okay
or another skin condition Vitiligo I
just did a post on Vitiligo not that
long ago and so there's different things
so let's take I think you mentioned
rosacea
all right so rosacea is characterized by
what looks to be a blushing of the the
sis of this face right so that kind of
chronic redness
and so what that means if we're if I'm
going to translate if I'm going to be
the body's translator what I would say
and and let me preface this by saying
this isn't going to resonate with
everybody
so oftentimes there's many different
things that the body could be saying but
it's within like usually five things so
one of the primary things contributors
to rosacea is over responsibility
and if we think about what that what how
is that metaphorically being represented
oftentimes when you are sort of stressed
out working hard you know you'll see
that your facial flush right there's
also so oftentimes what it comes from is
the feeling if we're talking about
really the root is maybe in your
childhood you felt overly responsible
maybe your parents were
um sick
disabled in some way
um possibly even could have been
alcoholics or maybe even just
emotionally
maybe not available or a little bit
emotionally immature remember we're not
judging it's no fault and so you got the
message as a young person
that you had to be responsible
you had to kind of take care of you and
so there was effort oh this could be
effort it's tough like I'm gonna have to
do this and it's showing up in your face
but you're also a little bit embarrassed
about it like you don't wanna I wanna
say anything negative about my family no
my family's good they're good they're
they did the best they could which I
believe but we're then still
invalidating the child's experience yes
two truths can be in the same space
that
your parents did the best they could
and you still didn't get enough
that can both truths can occupy that
same space so oftentimes that's the the
one of the contributors behind rosacea
is someone who is really like a
servaholic
that they serve in effort to get their
Worth or that's that's how they have
their worth in their family or their
place in their family so they they
overly serve
the body's showing it and it's because
so subconsciously they want to be seen
for that
but not consciously like consciously
like those kind of people don't put me
in that don't tell me
like I'm not in the spotlight about this
like I don't want you to bring attention
to the things that I'm doing
but deep inside they want the help they
want the they don't really have to be
their only resource yep
so their skin flushes okay so they want
to be seen that's incredible it makes
sense when you explain it when you die
when you break it down yeah okay so what
about like eczema or acne okay so eczema
is um there's a lot around eczema but
it's the body's um eczema is an
autoimmune disorder whenever we have an
autoimmune disorder we have this idea of
not being good enough it's a it's a deep
core belief that you have to sort of
fight for your worth fight for your
value and oftentimes we are really hard
on ourselves
so someone who does eczema is probably
Their Own Worst Enemy they're probably
thinking really hard things about
themselves very often and you've got to
think about what the body's thinking
about this you're turning on yourself
you need to be your biggest fan
you should love you most of all and
we're not we're not thinking Loving
Thoughts we're not having loving
behaviors within our our body and so
we've got this turning against oneself
which is an autoimmune condition
so what's supposed to protect us is now
showing that we are unprotected we're
vulnerable we're at risk and that's what
it's showing us and it
um another thing too it wants to be seen
but you it wasn't safe to be seen
usually in your family you don't want to
be the one that's high maintenance you
don't want to be the one that you would
probably
um
I mean again we've got to understand
people are doing the best they can but
you were probably not seen not validated
and so your skin is trying to show hey
we're hurting
so what about this is like a little
random segue but what about like a
childhood eczema because a lot of eczema
is like baby's childhood and does this
go back to at all about like the
ancestral stuff that we're talking about
depogenetics but it also could be if
you've got a parent that is has those
feelings and they're just deeply
undercover then um some of that does get
passed down so it can be if it's a baby
so almost all baby infant illnesses are
going to be either epigenetics so
ancestry that's passed down and
sometimes it can skip Generations too
like that stuff isn't cut and dry or it
could be some things that happened in
the womb so it's you know and again not
to do the guilt and shame or blame
please don't please don't do that it
doesn't serve anybody but stuff happens
when you're pregnant it can be in really
rough situations you can have an issue
at work you can have a fight with a
family member or an estrangement or with
a spouse
divorce and again like taking all this
in the consideration with the whole body
Wellness like you can consider the food
the lifestyle but let's also consider
the Mind aspect and all the stuff too
this is not to say like this is the only
thing right right right yes because we
there's a lot of different ways that we
will support
our real true belief systems the thing
is is if we really believe we are so
worthy so wonderful so incredible we are
purposed we are you know all of these
things inherently good we're gonna eat
food that nourishes us because we
believe we're worthy of nourishment yeah
we won't crave things that are um fake
and substitutes aren't supporting our
body right because that doesn't feel
congruent to us and it'll be we feel
like Cravings are outside of our control
and in a lot of ways they're outside of
our conscious control but they are
subconsciously based same with food
allergies a lot of stuff like that okay
all right so now let's get into acne
okay I know I'm sure you could talk
about the one specific thing for a
really long time a really long time just
for the purpose of this conversation to
be able to potentially meet the needs of
a lot of people who might be interested
in specific things we'll just kind of
like lightly touch on certain things and
keep moving along yes and I'm hearing
the call that this is something people
are really interested it in so I started
a social media every Friday I cover a
new condition and kind of go through
that but also I'm going to talk about it
I've had a podcast needing to start for
about four years but finally have the
first couple episodes recorded gonna be
amazing what's the podcast going to be
called Mind change podcast of course
super easy it's gonna be amazing and
then uh I plan on doing an episode a
week on conditions where I can talk and
get in a little bit more detail good
idea and then I would love to hear what
do people want to know about and that's
kind of how I'm doing my social media
posts right now is what people are
suggesting yeah so I'm hearing it we'll
get into it
um but let's say acne so acne is usually
something uh at some point in someone's
life and it's interesting that it comes
up a lot of times in teenage years we
just think it's hormonal or it's food or
whatever isn't it partly hormonal though
or would you say no are you like no it's
not I do think it's hormonal but how do
those hormones get produced okay all
right in excess it's like you keep going
another layer you keep going another
layer okay we control our hormone
production I know that that's we don't
want to think that we want to give it
outside of us but we do we produce our
neurotransmitter production we control
that with our thoughts with our with the
way that we uh set our homeostasis
within ourselves and our body then our
neurotransmitters just do what they're
supposed to do
so we do have a lot of control over that
hormonal conditions that I know people
get really like no I can't help my
hormones Yes actually we can we can but
I'm not saying that it's easy I'm not
saying that you should have known this
you should know this come on you should
come on fix your hormones I'm not saying
that no this is really about being like
vulnerable and open to just hear to hear
like okay what else is going on I'm
hoping and my my truest true is to say I
hope it empowers people if we can ship
the power back in let me tell you that's
what changes everything everything is
perspective because literally you could
take what you said and say how dare you
say it's my fault or you could say wow I
have control over this yes that's such
like amazing house like Stark difference
that is it's good news or bad news
depending on what you're doing in your
head and I haven't it's not me I know
you want it to be me and I'm sorry it's
all you have if you think it's me it's
your fault right there will be people
who are like Heather Jessica and they
want to do what they do that's fine
you're allowed but it's actually you get
to decide whether it's good news or bad
news it's your perception okay so get
back to the okay
acne is that you it's a lot of that
self-worth and that value is being given
outside of you
if people like me if I'm likable then
I'm okay and so it often and think about
this is so prevalent in teenage years
right because we're starting to the way
our brain is developing we're starting
to want to have an identity and yet we
still utilize all the stuff that's
around us to create our identity we're
like I'm gonna be what am I gonna be I
don't know what do you think I am right
who do you say I am but then I'm not
going to be that but it's still
sourced off of that right so it's that
thought that I'm not good enough and I
don't want or I'm this way if you really
knew who I was like if you could really
see you wouldn't like me and then it
comes up on our skin on our face wow
that's really interesting because I had
a lot of um High School acne and it was
always like oh well my dad had high
school acne so I got it it's like
inherited you know but my sister and my
mom didn't ever struggle with like acne
skin issues my sister never had acne in
high school to my understanding yeah and
it's interesting the way you're
describing that because I was very you
know in elementary school
um I definitely didn't have a lot of
friends
um at all I was just made fun of a lot I
wasn't cool at all in elementary school
so when I got to Junior High in high
school I was like okay it's a new school
my new chance to prove my worth to show
that like I'm likable I'm fun I'm you
want to be my friend right because it
was the reason why I got
um made fun of a lot was like I was just
too much for people I was very like hi
I'm Ellen you want to be my friend like
yeah I'm like just you know no walls up
you know and like and that is like
people are like oh wait no no like I'm
too cool for this like I can't no I
can't be your friend that was kind of
like what the response I got so then I
go to Junior High in high school I'm
like okay be cool just be cool like
don't be too much for people and so it
was that was like my story and so I
wonder how much of that is related
sounds like all of it
our internal is trying to come out
external yeah it's the most important
thing yeah our subconscious mind does
not care how we look on the outside yeah
it cares how we feel on the inside yes
and everything through Junior High and
high school which is like so many people
but then again so many people have acne
at that time yes but it's like just like
how can I like am I lovable am I likable
will I make any friends like that was
like the dominant thing on my mind and
how do we as teenagers because that's
where our brain development is right now
it's outward appearance it's what we see
yeah we don't go very deep we don't go
into the depths we and we've watched
parents do this we've watched people
judge we've watched and so we just judge
yeah oh you your Skin's bad yep you're
ugly wait what yeah like oh that's just
heartbreaking
it's just things on the skin but we make
these whole belief systems around it but
it's usually the inside trying to come
on to the outside to tell us something
of like that is not what makes you
beautiful or not beautiful and this was
not a story my sister went through like
my story that story of me and like
making sure like that was not her at all
like she was always like like very
confident who she was right yeah I'm
hilarious and if you don't like me
that's your problem right so you see
yeah we want to blame it on genetics and
we want to say it's just this but you
get two kids even sometimes identical
twins will have very different
manifestations physically yeah and
listen genetics go ahead and speak to
doctors we thought genetics was going to
be the end-all be-all and it's just not
they're more confused than ever yeah
totally it doesn't make sense no but
that's because our thoughts Express have
an effect over our gene expression right
but isn't it true though that maybe it
could be something could be the trigger
like maybe genetics are there yeah and
then it's like what is the trigger to
those genetics genetics are the gun yeah
environment is the bullets yeah so and
they both have to be there to sometimes
pull the triggers so yes absolutely I'm
not saying genetics doesn't have a play
but it can I mean obviously it doesn't
have to be that way okay so I want to
move on to the next one which would be
like chronic migraines or just migraines
in general yes have personal experience
with this oh you do yes I did migraines
I was on prescription migraine
medication starting at age 16. horrible
so I was doing a real nice like big time
but it was a familial thing everyone in
my family did migraines so we shared
medication yep so about migraines now
boy howdy this one's got a lot of stuff
I will say and so I've got a ton of
notes on this one so I'm going to kind
of be broad with it but
um this goes a little bit into that
whole mind brain heart brain gut brain
thing
uh polyvagal Theory which I love um Dr
porges talks a lot about the fact that
we've got this this grouping of nerves
that runs from our gut to our heart to
our brain and it really regulates
everything
and my belief system is our gut is the
place that has is is really where we
store our
um most true self it's whether you call
that Soul Spirit energy whatever it's
that like spark that we have that we are
collective we come from something we all
have this and we'll return to something
and it's bigger and it's more powerful
and somehow we can kind of all feel it
some people are way more connected to it
and others have just Associated from it
I feel like metaphorically that lives in
the gut it's our intuition it's why we
say gut feeling or if some if you're
betrayed it feels like a gut punch right
because it's this it's this place where
all of our inherent and internal wisdom
is
we learn very very early to shut that
down it's so sad but we teach kids that
they're too extra that their emotions
are too much that they're wrong you
shouldn't have that emotion for this
thing like we just teach them so young
that to disconnect from their intuition
you're gonna let me do this for you
you're probably gonna mess this up
you're just gonna keep making mistakes
until you're older right and then they
get this idea that they're not like they
don't have it figured out and that they
need to you know rely on somebody else
to tell them what to do that shuts our
gut down
how many gut issues do people have right
and think about digestion and everything
so then it comes up to our heart
and if you're just in your heart without
the internal thing and you're just a
ball of emotions and feelings and in a
world that that's just not safe we're
not taught how to manage that correctly
you're so vulnerable
you go so high and so low and if an
adult doesn't regulate for you that you
can co-regulate with and they are very
they are able to you know handle their
own selves we're just all over the place
quickly learn as a big feeler that's not
safe
so we start to shut down our heart and
then we're stuck in our head
when you're stuck in your head thinking
thoughts about your thoughts and that's
how you stay safe we get perfectionism
we get a lot of different
um the what ifs they what if everything
they try to see everything that is
happening to mitigate responses to
mitigate issues so they think think
think think think and it hurts your head
it legit hurts your head your head is
too full of all of this stuff all the
time and your brain feels like it's
swelling and you will get migraines
because you're in your head way too much
you're catastrophic thinking you're
creating bad what-if scenarios you're
trying to think the only way to stay
safe is if you can think through every
scenario that could happen that's really
interesting anyone listening
what's your issue let's see how that
resonates another one would be what's
the other one fibromyalgia oh fiber is a
good one I did that one as well so
um the fibro also is a autoimmune
disorder and it's a progressive one
normally it is not someone's first
diagnosis so it is one of those
diagnoses on that trajectory so usually
you'll have some other chronic fatigue
maybe beforehand some other stuff but
fibro one of the biggest things with
fibro is the feeling that you're not
safe
that you are at risk of being hurt
really is the thing and that you so that
usually goes into somehow in childhood
it could even be pre-verbal
and there's a lot of different ways you
felt exposed to pain
to that you were gonna be in bad
situations
and so you started to make belief
systems around yourself and who you were
and what that meant about you and
interestingly if you take spinal fluid
of a fibromyalgia patient they actually
have more receptors for pain
so it isn't that they are they they are
actually experiencing more pain they've
opened themselves up to more pain they
feel things that you wouldn't feel
because you don't have as many pain
receptors but they expanded their pain
receptors because they're so aware that
there's pain everywhere they expect pain
they anticipate pain so the body
listened and it created more receptors
for pain
and now they have chronic pain wow
that's so fascinating it's so
fascinating a lot of times if I'm
something like fibromyalgia pops up
later in life yes but you're saying that
it could happen something
starts starts when you're younger early
yes wow fibromyalgia is
born conceived in childhood
and over time it's it develops and you
start to see it in adulthood I really
think if we keep on this path you'll
start seeing it younger and younger as
with all these chronic diseases which
were never in childhood well we didn't
even have them before the majority of
these chronic illnesses that we are so
comfortable with now did not exist
before why is that because we didn't
have so much Collective trauma that we
weren't dealing with so you're talking
about like the Collective Now talking
about the collective an individual like
we just haven't like we we are taught to
work and to not feel feelings and and
when you've got so many and man don't
get me started on how in America at
least with the war where you take all
the men away and the women now are in
these you know roles of having to also
provide for the family and there's this
whole shift that happens there you've
got all these men coming back
traumatized they're not knowing how to
deal with it it affects the whole family
stress structure you can trace a lot of
this stuff back yeah but you know there
were Wars since the beginning of time
right so is it possible that maybe
people were experiencing like
fibromyalgia but just like didn't have
the words for it oh yes definitely these
things aren't new in the sense that yeah
no one ever felt this stuff before right
it was less
we had Outlets we were way more
connected we were in family structures
so we had a lot more connection we had a
lot more safety yeah because because you
could look at like you know that you
said something about work you could
almost argue that there was more work
like the labor in regards to like
physical labor and things like that
right from back then but the amount the
way that we live our lives now is so
disconnected right but physical labor
would have at least had you in your body
like it would have had you in your body
feeling your body and and that was there
was there's good stuff with that we
released trauma yeah through physical
activity yeah and right now we are in
such an age where you're just like
screen screen sit down do nothing yeah
and work the the posture that we take
sitting in front of a computer is a
traumatized posture it actually Keeps Us
in a trauma posture right so we're
hunched we're scrunched we're this yeah
our head is tipped down yeah
if we've got our chin down these are
trauma responses in the body yeah so
even if you maybe don't come from a ton
of trauma what you're telling your body
on a day-to-day basis is that things
something's dangerous something's not
okay yeah there's like so much Beauty to
this new age that we live in now of
internet and access to reach each other
so quickly and everything like that but
there's definitely downsides right we
have to we really just have to be aware
and it's not to say things are bad yeah
bad good all perception and judgment but
let's be aware of the contributing
factors right that's what I love I'm
just curious I'm like okay let's step
back and go what are all the I just want
information right what's all the
information that I can get yeah so
you're if you are doing fibromyalgia
that's information let's talk about the
information what could that be let's
talk about some possible factors yeah
and then then you've got the power of
what you're going to do with that
totally okay I'm gonna ask one more
specific you know issue and anyone who's
interested in hearing more definitely go
follow your Instagram it's just mind
change right yeah just my change just my
change straight up mind change you know
because you're going to keep posting
about them we obviously can't cover
everything there's so many things but it
really just shows you that like how hurt
everyone's just walking around hurt and
a lot of it is like in your mind and
it's like it's like heart hurt yes or
and like you said the gut hurt and the
Brain but and it's real it's real and
that we feel it yeah it's a real it's a
real feeling all these things all these
things are real we're not saying they're
not real yeah and they are tragic and
they are painful and it's awful and when
you're in the midst of it it feels like
you're never gonna see the light yeah so
I get that and I know that but there is
light yeah well that's the same thing of
like the first reason why we got ever
got into this conversation together if
you don't know you probably know by now
if you have been following my life for a
while but Heather and I used to be
neighbors and I was going into my third
birth I was pregnant and my first two
labors first two bursts were wonderful
empowering beautiful I love them amazing
home births but they were definitely
extremely long extremely painful and I
wanted to do it different this time and
I was just talking to you know my
neighbor Heather just being like oh man
I really wish that it could just feel
better like just people who say that it
doesn't that it's not painful and I just
don't get that like what I felt was like
legit that was pain like There Is No
One's Gonna convince me that if someone
else felt that that they would say that
wasn't painful like how are they doing
it not painful and she's like well you
know you could do it differently you
know I'm like what are you talking about
and that's how we got into it yeah yeah
you were skeptical at first I was so
skeptical I literally was like skeptic
to the nines like I was like all right
I'm gonna try this thing but good luck
and you're like well you don't even have
to believe that it's gonna work and
it'll still work and I was like really
like I was like what I don't believe
that what is this thing if you know
Ellen like you're not like a you I'm not
just gonna jump on it I'm like you need
to prove it to me right you're not like
well I like you Heather so I think I'll
just believe you yeah no I'm not I'm not
not like that person at all so then when
you know we did one mind change session
together with your husband kit and a few
days later went to labor and had the
most euphoric birth pleasurable didn't
feel pain it was incredible I couldn't
even believe it like I was like laughing
through Labor and by the end after I
gave birth I was like what in the heck
did I just do like it was the most
empowering birth for me because it's the
first time that I like did something
that I that I wanted to do like I told
my body what to do and when I felt so in
control it was super empowering
um anyways I don't know why I brought
that up other than to say why did I
bring that up
right
I don't remember either it's such a good
story though I know that's okay though
but let's get into the last one which is
inside no insomnia that's a really
common one yes okay so insomnia if when
we sleep is when our subconscious mind
gets gets the the attention right it's
in control most of the time but it's
very back in the back of the Mind
Control right so in this when we sleep
is when the subconscious mind actually
gets the the space to file and sort and
uh figure out whether this is a neural
pathway we want to keep investing in
it'll strengthen a neural pathway if
it's one that we haven't used in however
long it'll degrade that one and start to
like not let that be you know useful to
us anymore it's it puts our memory in
whichever category and stores it in the
part of the brain okay so that's what's
happening in the subconscious mind
that's why we have weird dreams is
because it's doing all this metaphoric
stuff
if we have a hard time letting go of
control
if keeping control is really important
for us if we have a deep investment in
maybe our
intellect or in like making sure we've
got our eyes on everything that I can
kind of figure out everything and that's
our constant way of being productive I
need to be productive I need to do these
things then sleep for us feels
subconsciously like I'm wasting time I
need to be more product producing I need
to be thinking where I need to be
figuring things out
what we don't realize is that is when we
figure stuff out like when our
subconscious mind has the space and the
time to put everything where it needs to
be and check it with our Collective
awareness with our our mind's Collective
awareness
that's when like
it's the old adage like why don't you
sleep on it if you sleep on it you'll
come out with a better knowledge
we inherently know that we've known that
since before brain science even existed
so the collect we know that once that we
sleep we're going to kind of understand
things better
so when someone isn't sleeping
it it starts because they're trying to
stay into conscious control
that to to let go of that control feels
scary feels dangerous for some reason or
feels unproductive
and again we're not thinking that
consciously you're not sitting there
going you know I think I'd just like to
stay in control and that's why I'm going
to stay up all night
and
so the brain just does that and we are
we're breaking through so some people
have a hard time falling asleep some
people will be woken up in the middle of
the night and can't get back to sleep
and that's what it is we've got these
warring they're supposed to work
together they're meant to work together
and what we've got is these opposing
forces where the conscious mind needs to
stay aware awake aware and in control so
they can be productive and a lot of
times it comes because productivity is
worth I'm only worthy if I'm producing
I'm only worthy like people will only
accept me and like me if I'm you know
doing what I need to be doing and this
is my value and this is my and they also
are thinking a lot there's also a lot of
thinking happening yeah a lot of times
it's so like this one insomnia in
particular is very clearly just like
your mind and when you're thinking
because a lot of times it's like you
can't stop thinking you can't just shut
your brain off yeah that'll but people
will say I just have all these things
that pop up and you know this pops up
and that pops up and and it's just
because there's also sometimes a lack
mentality like but there's not enough
time and there's not enough and if I
don't do this now and it's a little bit
of a frantic kind of energy and to sleep
feels useless it feels like it's not
worthy of like I'm gonna miss something
and it's totally the opposite and then I
will say what usually happens after that
is someone has an experience with
insomnia where they start to link things
together so they do the insomnia in
their bedroom or whatever and they'll
plan for it they start to plan for it
oh is it what am I going to do if I
don't sleep tonight mm-hmm
so already your brain's like okay so
what so we're not sleeping tonight are
we not sleeping tonight are we planning
to not sleep tonight okay it just
listens and so you do these things and
then I I've even had people who've made
lists of the things that they're going
to do that night while they're not
sleeping wow because they know that
they're not gonna sleep so and it's the
confirmation and everything obviously
not not able to get into everything in
this one episode but if you look listen
to the first episode we did it talks
about like the confirmation all the
evidence that this is true this is going
to happen yes and a lot of times it's a
story my guess is someone in the family
didn't sleep well or they were told as a
baby they were a bad sleeper that's
exactly Hannah's story yes exactly
that's right my sister has a whole video
with you on the topic of insomnia and my
my mom had the story Growing Up Oh Ellen
always slept because we're only five
months apart Ellen always slept so good
but Hannah she would always wake Ellen
up and I had to go put her in the
separate area all by herself yeah and
that becomes a thing like when you're
compared as a sibling holy moly does
that do a number on us yeah and that
belief system of well I'm not a good
sleeper I've never been a good sleeper
and that becomes a way to do insomnia
really well okay so for people listening
who are like okay I know what my you
know thing or things are or at least I
have a understanding of like hey I need
to work on myself and my mind I read
your book maybe like took your course or
something and they're like well how do I
just handle day to day
things that come up or if a symptom
comes up like where what are some useful
practical tools people can do
when something comes up in their day
that they would like to change either in
their mind or their physical symptoms to
help them throughout their day to just
to optimize their life yes great
question
what I have seen people do is get a
little bit stuck in this and it becomes
like a psychoanalyzation so now
everything they think what am I doing
what is this setting what could this be
in childhood yeah and they start to let
me tell you that's all conscious mind
thought and it doesn't that's not where
we have any real work to be done it's
really our subconscious mind it's the
way that we've stored experiences and
the way that those get represented so
this comes from NLP neuro-linguistic
programming this idea around the way
that we store information so we store it
in either kinesthetically and we let me
tell you if an experience happens you
are using all of your senses to store
that information but each individual
human does it maybe more primarily in
one of these six ways kind of like if
you're an auditory learner or a visual
learner right and that doesn't mean you
just are yeah that there you don't learn
any other way it's just your primary way
your brain's favorite way of doing it
yeah so we utilize that too when we're
working with people so I will ask people
like if you've got an issue and the
first bet and best question is well how
do I know this is happening now with the
how do I know we don't want to be like
judgy with ourselves or anything it's
like okay
is it a feeling in my body is it a
memory in the fact that see memory
feeling is memory but we think memories
generally are visual constructs but
feelings are memories too sounds or
memories all of these different things
but we need to find out how I'm doing it
so if I have something let's say I'm in
a conversation with someone and I feel
that triggered feeling and I realize
something comes up in me so what I will
do at that moment is I will go okay I
feel that I'll acknowledge it in myself
right oh I feel that I hear you I notice
and that helps my body so much even if I
just cognitively I'm like okay I hear
you I'm getting the message something's
up here there's information here and
that's the way I look at it oh
information just happened Ellen didn't
do anything to even if you did even if
you were like a emotionally immature you
know like you don't have awareness and
you said a really jerky thing yeah
still the way I perceive that is mine
right if I if I could if universally we
could say that was kind of a jerky thing
to say I could say in my mind Ellen is a
jerk or I can go how interesting Ellen
said a jerky thing
or at least that's the way I perceived
it I wonder what's going on with Ellen
if I just know that it's not me or what
if it maybe is me I want to check that
first so I'll go okay wait a minute wait
a minute or maybe I won't do that like
that I'll be like I will sort of become
internal for a second like oh I'm aware
that something is happening inside of me
and I'm gonna regulate me
so what I feel like that any of that
let's say it's a physical
I'm going to use the word dysregulation
so dysregular how do I know there's a
dysregulation either I'm put back in a
situation so some people call those
flashbacks that's a dysregulation
because I'm here now I'm not there but
all of a sudden my head's there and
sometimes my body can be there too
dysregulation we've got that's not
shouldn't I should be here not there but
it's happening so I'm not going to judge
it I'm just going to become aware of it
or let's say I have a feeling in my body
I all of a sudden feel like that heart
racy feeling or I feel sick to my
stomach or I feel like I want to move
away from you all of these are feelings
inside my body that are there for a good
reason
so that's my first and foremost thing
that I say I'm feeling something it's
for a good reason
it may not be something I want to keep
doing but it's good I have a good reason
for doing it at least the way my mind
feels about it so if I have the moment
to do it then I might not like I might
be in a conversation or talking with my
boss and now is not the time for me to
check out and do all this internal work
I will shelf it
in the sense that okay I'm aware that
something happened I am going to check
in with this later when I have the space
the safety and the time and the space to
do this so I'm gonna just put it over
here
but I'm not I'm not avoiding I'm not
judging I'm not saying
there's anything wrong with this I'm I'm
acknowledging it and I'm saying and
making a commitment that I'm going to
get to it later
okay so then if I when I'm home and when
I'm in my space that I can do this then
I'll go and sort of unpack this okay
what was really happening
she said this and I felt this how do I
know well I felt this feeling inside of
me and I'll sometimes ask myself the
question okay well when else have I felt
this feeling
and when I say when else if I felt this
feeling I'm looking for probably the
proof that came way before this
conversation to say oh I felt this
before this isn't new Ellen just
triggered something listen if you can
trigger something in me that means
there's something there
I always use this same example and I
know it's silly but I say if you were to
say to me you know you're a purple alien
I'd be like
oh no you're a purple alien
I can't believe you purple aliens I'd be
like are you okay you're like I'm not a
person okay because listen I know like
I'm not a purple alien it didn't happen
not you cannot convince me otherwise
yeah I'm sorry I love you but no
I would immediately go are you like are
you okay are you being serious like
what's happening right now I would be
very confused because that doesn't that
doesn't resonate with me at all
now if you say Heather you are so needy
I'd be like
because I'd be like oh that resonates
like I'm so afraid that you would think
that about me but that's mine
is it true that I'm needy I don't know
is it I gotta check in with myself where
is that coming from why does that hurt
me so bad why did that scare me so much
that you would say that about me yeah oh
yeah I mean that goes that reminds me of
like my own personal experience of being
online and what people can say and you
know there's a lot of opinions a lot of
just opinions that people have about
anything that you put online and someone
can say something about me that's very
negative and there are times when it
doesn't affect me at all oh that doesn't
basically doesn't resonate no I'm not
like that they they think that I'm like
that but whatever then there are times
when someone says that you are this or
you look like this or whatever and if I
have that feeling already inside me
that's when it's ah I can't believe
someone thinks that about me I am like
that oh you know that's such a
difference how certain things can affect
you and others don't
know and people are hurting that's
really what it is most people are so
nice but yeah it's the it's the evidence
how you like prop up like a negative
um experience like that like something
you read because there's a difference
between constructive thought versus sure
versus completely unconstructive and you
know okay whatever that person's going
through that day like that's what that's
for them disagree with me yeah be
curious yeah I'm curious about your
disagreement like that's curious yeah
there's such a difference there but if I
have to like judge you because of the
way if I have to somehow Take You Down
for that for you to be in question
that's something different that's me not
feeling good about me yeah and I'm now
trying to make you look bad so I feel
better and there's so many layers to
like being online people would say say
something online they would never say to
the person in real life like so 100
there's all that but anyway sorry go
ahead but that's the the truth of that
though is like why do some comments
really sting and otherwise others don't
bypass yeah if they're let's say they're
a bunch of negative comments together
where it's just not constructive but
just nasty why why are some nasty ones
like someone said that I know they must
have been having a really hard day yes
well you can do that like oh shame they
must be yeah poor person you know how
can we you know help so that that's not
them having a super high day versus like
oh that hits you like a bullet that's
ours yeah that the bullets ours the
trade if it can be triggered it's in us
and that's where a lot of therapy up
until this point has been helping people
manage triggers and cope with these
things and and listen I'm all for
anything that helps us feel better
except that long term it doesn't help us
feel better we actually end up feeling
worse because we're still not listening
if you trigger me there's something
there I get really curious about this
now when I'm listening to someone and
something happens inside my body I'm
like oh look you're there so oh looky
there's something to heal something to
get into some information for me to dive
deeper in and now I think I'm an amazing
adventure I don't think I'm a hot mess
like I don't think I'm broken I don't
think I'm this the way that I used to
really Define myself don't believe it
anymore
so now a trigger to me can be like
information I'm so curious about myself
like where did this come from what's
happening with me so that's really my
first step in in figuring that out is
saying this is information and hey body
and mind I'm listening now
I'm listening and it's okay you're safe
to tell me talk to me talk
talk right like let's do this and that
just creates this space I feel like for
there to be now some internal
conversation that can be useful
so then I'll recognize okay
how do I know this thing bothered me and
oftentimes let's say you said I was
needy and that's what I was going for
and I was like making me feel sad then
I'm gonna go in my space and go okay
what was the real problem with that the
Ellen thinks I'm needy why does that
bother me so much because I love Ellen
and I don't want her to think I'm needy
because if she's if she thinks I'm needy
she's not going to want to really be
with me okay interesting doesn't mean
that's true it just is my I'm gonna put
all my belief systems out there I'm not
gonna judge him I'm just going to
observe them and put them out there okay
but why is that so scary to me when else
did I feel like being needy wasn't okay
and let me just tell you the
vulnerability like when I was a child I
grew up with my mom's an addict and I
mean she had so much trauma
of her own and the the using was an
effort to mitigate her own stuff
but for me to be needy as a child
was so hard because it would make her
feel so bad because she couldn't meet
those needs and it made her feel so
terrible about herself she would
downward spiral
so for me to have needs was not okay not
safe I had to be so good all the time
I'm fine I'm always fine what do you
need actually as a little person and so
that to me for you to call me needy
would be like trigger trigger trigger
now I will say it's not that triggery
for me anymore yeah so I'm kind of going
into that thing I would if you said that
to me I'd be like interesting yeah so
tell me how you're getting there yep
like what is it that you're observing
about me and I would be more Curious now
than it being like like my heart rate
wouldn't have to rise right so how did
you get there from where something like
that would trigger you so much that's
like a daily tool and a daily what's a
daily tool in practice that can help
someone get from there to where what the
other part that you're saying where it's
not as trickery yes that aspect okay
that's that
being able to look back and go okay well
what is my history so I have people do
what we call a pain cure list and it's
past negative experiences and current
realities it's a little acronym or
whatever wasn't trying to be cute with
it it just came out that way and so it
was really and it's an inventory to say
okay this is what I
these are the things that I think
happened you know and let me tell you
it it was a bit devastating in the
beginning for me because I was like
really stuff started to come out and I
thought oh my gosh this is terrible
stuff but then I sort of understood I I
mean with the way memory works and
everything like that this is just my
representation
this is my story and for me it is a
story I don't know what is actually true
true but it's true to me and that's
important so I just put it all out there
and then I started to work on some of
that stuff so
for me a huge thing was practically for
me was working on my relationship with
my mom
but we were estranged so it's not like I
could actually just sit down and work
stuff out with my mom in fact that's
doesn't usually go well because it's so
much of internal representation
so I had to look back through and go
through my childhood so let's say on a
practical level
how did I know that I couldn't get my
needs met and so for me I represent
um very initially visually so I would
have a visual come up and this is going
to be tougher for me because I really
don't have I'm gonna have to kind of
probably make something up but um
let's say
I I would remember maybe my mom not
being able to buy groceries
let's say right I mean that was a a
truth too just with our our
circumstances when I was growing up and
feeling hungry but feeling like I can't
say any things and it'll make her feel
bad
so then what do I do with that so I will
go back and I will see how do I know
that this bothers me like I see the
visual I see her face you know I see her
face of like not being able to provide
for her own children
and I had to kind of think through that
now I'm a mom of my own how would I feel
if I couldn't put groceries on the table
like how would I feel I would feel
devastated and I didn't really consider
that as a I couldn't as a child you
can't consider that as a child you don't
have that awareness
but even as a young adult I never really
was able to Think Through wait what did
that do to her
and I'm not bypassing me I will get to
me in a minute but her face really
bothered me and I know because I'd go
back and see that look on her face right
so what I would do is step inside of my
mom and think okay if this were me how
would I be feeling
I would be devastated I would put
nothing more than to put food on the
table for my kids
and what is I what is that doing that
I'm not able to it makes me feel
terrible about myself
and I already feel so terrible about
myself
and I don't want to feel terrible about
myself and so I'm going to really make
it more about like no it's it's no big
deal like you ate yesterday right or
something that would be the most
ridiculous thing that a parent would say
she isn't she's in herself now she's
trying to deal with her she can't if she
can't even figure out her how she gonna
take care of a little one we really want
that to be the case but guys we can only
give like
what we really have you know and so that
started to I started to have a shift of
perspective
and go okay that look on her face was
about her
that disdain that
was not about me that was about her now
as a child I perceived it it was about
me
so I I gave space for there to be okay
if she didn't have to worry about that
if if she if she'd feel good about her
what would she if she was in her most
high self what would she do and she'd
come over and she'd be like I know I'm
hungry too like I'm sorry what if we
could like what if like if we had a
spread on the table like what would we
eat and how would that be and engage
with me like validate me and say I'm so
sorry and be there for me doesn't mean
that that would put actual food on the
table
but would it long term what if my mom
started really feeling good about
herself what if she could feel like man
listen I am I'm doing the best that I
can and I'm loving this kid
and I am with her and I'm motivated
Tomorrow there's gonna be food on the
table and she would go out and you know
we think what keeps us doing is like
guilt and shame let me tell you the her
amount of guilt and shame just caused
her to try to use again because it's too
much for any human to carry and then no
more food got put on the table
you know so it's like it really does
have profound changes I really do
believe
if she had that ability to see herself
as
worthy and good and a great mother she
could have validated that with me and
she could have just hugged me and said
sorry it sucks we don't have food on the
table like let's go find food let's go
do something together let's go adventure
maybe we can do something and find food
that would have meant more to me than
the look that I perceived on her face
which was that disdain for herself which
I internalized for me and got the
message that I have to pretend I'm not
hungry
I can't have to pretend I'm not me I
don't have this need of food
which is just silly so I went and did
that in my mind
and all of that plays out in my mind
right and then all of a sudden guess
what happens my body starts feeling
better like I start to be like
I did I did have needs and I should have
gotten them met and she did the best she
could and if she would have had she
would have given me it meant nothing
about me I'm so worthy of getting my
needs met and and I could love her and
she could love me and we could hug and
it would be amazing and it released me
it released me from the belief that I
wasn't worthy of having my needs met
absolutely so was I needy uh no I was
hungry because humans need food yep and
that was okay and it was okay for her to
know that about me too and it motivated
her then to go and do something
different from a positive place like um
I am gonna do this that's incredible
thanks for sharing all that that is like
such an incredible story too
just be able to hear like what you went
through and how you peeled from and I
think it's helpful for you for people to
know too that like when they're finding
themselves in a place where you know
blood the blood is rising and they're
feeling the anxiety and the stress
coming how to take a moment take a pause
go back to what could be potentially
causing that trigger and so much of what
mind change is is going back to that
experience like and feeling it like you
have to go to the place that you don't
want to go yes and actually feel the
feelings feel it let yourself feel it
because in in a lot of the a lot of the
things people are just pushing it to the
side it's not there it's not real just
positive affirmations right but that
doesn't like take away what what you
felt or they want to get in and feel
worse about it like you I can't believe
like she should have and she was a
terrible person and uh then we just feel
more terrible within ourselves yeah so
you have to get there and then you have
to rewire the brain which is what you do
basically right so her face was a memory
I have a neural pathway based on that
look on her face that's how I stored
that information visually so all of it
was held visually in that look on her
face when the look on her face changed
it like set my it rewired that oh now
that's that look like I can't see her do
that other look anymore I can only see
The Look of Love
now this okay I'm gonna hear the people
who are like yeah but okay
so what you're just gonna pretend like
it was okay that you didn't have food on
the table no I'm not saying that I just
said in fact I can say more than ever I
should have had there should have been
food on the table but I understand like
holding my mom hostage in my head that
she should have done better she should
have provided like when I know of that
woman's history it
her even just
putting one foot in front of the other
every day was a huge success for her so
and it doesn't let her off the hook it
doesn't
none of that stuff that's not what I'm
looking to do but I stay hostage if I
hold her in that space for your whole
life for my whole life then the way the
brain works and and a confirmation bias
and everything if I think that my needs
are not worth being met and that people
won't if that's my belief system from
childhood my own mother my own mother
didn't meet my needs
now I'm going to find that Everywhere I
Go I'm going to find that in my jobs now
my bosses don't even see how hard I work
and they don't even have to do
everything I'll find it in my marriage
he never does anything it's me I have to
take care of the kids have to do this I
have to do this I have to do this
and I'll just recreate
that wound because I'm trying to heal it
that's the thing I don't we don't
realize that we're actually trying to
heal it so we keep recreating it until
it's reconciled
it doesn't get reconciled that way by
continuing to recreate it but our
brain's trying and our body's telling us
and it keeps it's triggering us to go
hey you need to get rid of this so that
like you got to change this you're still
holding on to this you're not that
little girl anymore that hungry little
girl anymore
plenty of food you can do like it's okay
and Mom would have given it to you had
she it meant nothing about you I need to
go back and set that little girl free
because otherwise I will keep those
belief systems even though it was
how old am I 46. I was like 42 years ago
yeah I could still be holding on to
something a belief system that affects
me now that's not serving you anymore
not serving me which is the victim
victim versus victimhood yes it did
serve me then then
if I would have spoken up in the way
that I would now she wouldn't have been
able to handle that at the place where
she was out at the time yeah would have
just made her feel a thousand times
worse which would have spiraled her
further so as a child I did the best
that I could she was doing the best she
could I am not that little girl anymore
I don't want to keep doing it that way I
don't want to have to keep being needy
or or pretending I don't have needs
because I do every human does and it
shows up in neediness in other ways yeah
which was my my sickness my illness I
can't take care of myself someone has to
take care of me and they can't make me
feel guilty about it because clearly I
can't do it on my own oh and I still
felt awful about that I was still so
ashamed of that right but I stayed in it
and my husband if you've heard our story
he did he was the he was the one he came
in and he rescued and he took care of me
and I'll do anything for you which
sounds amazing doesn't it
but that's not the real I could like
it's okay and I can be okay and still
have that yeah I don't have to be sick
to get that yep and I encourage anybody
to go listen to or watch our first
episode together with Kent and Heather
McKean so her and her husband especially
going to this if this is your first time
hearing about this you might be like
okay so how do you rewire the brain
definitely go watch the first one we're
probably not going to get much into that
now because we're going to close out
soon but go watch the first one because
we really explain the difference of just
living in it versus like changing it
rewiring the brain yes um and so much of
it of it the way you explain it is like
going to the places you don't want to go
to those stories those experiences that
hurt you emotionally or physically any
of that and then changing the story and
a lot of it is like wishing you had the
Heather in your head to get there
because because so much of it is
conversational you know like you're
there and you're sitting and you're like
I don't know why I'm feeling you this
way but this is what I felt and then
it's the perspective of like bringing
new evidence to the table well isn't it
true that because of this that this this
is why maybe why your mother responded
this way maybe she was hurting because
of this and all those things that bring
different evidence for you to help you
understand what was really happening or
rewiring your brain for maybe something
happened the way that you really felt it
but to be able to heal from that yes and
it well I will say and you said it
before it's it's not just it's not easy
but it is simple like the the how we do
it is simple and it's all in the book so
it's not like oh like you need to spend
a bunch of money to figure this stuff
out it's in the book it's all there yeah
the application of it though is it's a
lot of work it can be yeah but more
because we don't know how to do this
it's a completely counter-intuitive so
true it's so true it's like practice it
takes practice if you were raised this
way if you were born into a mind change
Community oh my gosh and you knew how
powerful you were and you watched other
people take personal responsibility this
would be like breathing air it would be
like oh this and this oh I I want a
different neural pathway with that I
want a different outcome of that so I'm
going to change this we would just do it
and so much of it starts with like if
you're raising children like okay how do
I practice this with my kids so that
they're growing up like confident
self-responsible you know all that so
much of it is like checking in when
you're feeling a feeling pull back ask
yourself questions find evidence here
and there and you can change that yes oh
my gosh having children was the biggest
challenge to that right of like their
mirrors to you they are mirrors and then
I have to check in with my own
regulation like is am I disregular
because if I go dysregulated you just
watch you're about ready to watch
something they're gonna just hit the
roof in some way if I disregulate
because children do not possess the
ability to self-soothe so contrary to
all that stuff they say they don't
actually possess the hardware to
self-soothe they co-regulate
so we that who do they co-regulate to us
yeah they see what we're doing and then
they do it and they feel what we're
feeling see they're live wires they
haven't learned all these ways to
disconnect from God yet and their brain
is still developing yep and so they are
very non they're they're they're still
very non-verbal in the sense that they
can read our body language which is
adults we kind of forget about but
children are so so the looks on our
faces the way we breathe they pick up on
all of that
and so if we're not truly regulated they
know and they disregulate so it's a it's
such a huge responsibility it is I go to
bed thinking about that all the time but
it's also a huge healing opportunity
yeah because what if we teach them that
like whoa I just went out and let me
take personal responsibility for coming
back in that is like one of the we need
three questions
give me a minute give me to apologize
acknowledge where you messed up like all
that is like so helpful assumptions like
when you said that I assumed this and I
didn't even give you a chance to say
what were you really feeling like if we
model this yeah but we've got to do it
to ourselves yes it can't be fake we
can't just you know a lot of people run
into this like gentle parenting kind of
like yeah because we aren't parenting
ourselves that way so true we can't be
complete and utter jerks to ourself
yeah
yeah no no it doesn't work that way we
have to first reparent ourselves and
then create space to do that with the
others we have to be real they know it
they know when we're not doing it for
real and it makes us even more mad yeah
I'm trying to be gentle right like
it's just
fires us up but they you know they are
looking for and I love that about kids
they want us real I know they want us
authentic the truest of true if we're
sad they want us to cry if we're happy
they want us to joyfully laugh if we're
confused they want to be like what the
heck we don't even get this they want to
see that it's all okay to feel their
feelings yes and if they because that's
the only way they get permission is to
watch the way that we do it right so
it's a lot with us and this is the the
and I see it as a privilege to be able
to be like oh my gosh I'm this far in my
journey and I'm still learning and I say
that to my kids I think I probably said
that last week to my teenage daughter
yeah it's like never had an almost 16
year old before a first time being here
yep like never done this before we're
doing this together I need your feedback
like I need to know what I just need to
know just yeah how few how few parents
are doing that I need your feedback tell
me tell me what's up I'm like I'm doing
my best yeah this is my best if it's not
good enough for you I need you to be
able to say that because I I don't
really know I'm happy to adjust that's
something I'm not reading in the
parenting books
well I'm like that's I had to say that
though because I'm like no I think no
I'm saying like that's that's really
interesting and insightful I needed to
say like I this is the best I've got
because that's how you are even with
your relationships like you have to be
able to be open to receive the feedback
yes and I I have to be gentle with
myself too to be like this is all I have
doesn't mean I can't get more though I'm
open for more so I'm doing my best how's
that Landing with you because if it
doesn't land with you my best isn't
going to be your best and we need to
talk about that yeah because I might be
like hey I'm doing my best so sorry
kiddo you need to just deal with it and
now they've just been invalidated
they've not been seen I haven't held a
space for them I can figure stuff out
I'm open but I only have what I have so
I can get more if I'll be told I am
still teachable and I'm I'm able to
learn and that alone is such good
modeling for kids yeah I would hope so
that you're teachable right stay
teachable yep okay so as we run out of
this conversation we could keep going
and going but I want to round it out a
little bit and just talk about how we
work together on my pregnancy course
that I created with my sister Hannah
it's called the empowered pregnancy and
birth and you were such an important
addition to this course can you kind of
talk a little bit about how mind change
affects your birth because you're in
like for anyone who doesn't know you are
in this course there's an entire module
dedicated to mind change to have the
birth that you desire of your dreams and
that anything holding you back from what
you think birth is supposed to feel like
um and you don't want it to feel that
way that's what we rewire in the course
yes so one of the things that I say in
the course is that birth giving birth is
a skill
and it also right it's right butted up
against it and it's also an innate
ability but it is a skill so we can
alter it so it's something we should be
able to physiologically do naturally
easily and why don't we though and
that's because we have been we're so
adaptable and we've adapted to this
there's so much history on why we've
adapted to this sort of pain default
around pregnancy there's a lot of stuff
that happens with us in pregnancy it's
one of those oh my gosh healing
opportunities
because from an evolutionary standpoint
we don't want to pass things down that
didn't feel good for us
somehow we know that deep deep deep
inside so what is really there we know
might really get passed down and it's
this space that opens up for us to go oh
I want to be a little more selective
about what I am passing down so
oftentimes a lot more comes up
and a lot and we perceive a lot of these
things that we haven't dealt with is
pain
and so what does our body do there's
pain in it and if we really think
there's stuff that we haven't dealt with
that we didn't know how to we still as
adults
still don't know how to deal with and
process and we're still carrying and
we're about to give birth to a child the
body's a little bit more liquid hold on
right and it's this whole like kind of
posture
which is counter-intuitive for birth
that goes up against that's a
maladaption for what we naturally do
right fetal ejection responses that our
body our we the baby comes to a certain
spot and we just like out comes baby
just bloop out about it pops yep easy
everything opens we are built that way
were designed that way but there is a
story around birth that tells us
otherwise and it holds you back it
really does it so holds you back your
body you can talk about that forever I
know I love birth I love birth too I'm
so fascinated by our bodies and oh and I
re I'm so I'm so grateful that you
included me in this and that honestly
you opened this whole portal
I had never been asked about mind change
with birth before you well didn't even
I literally was like what
that's a great question because I was
mentioning it you're like well yeah I
mean with you know the everything in
revolves about the mind yeah you could
totally do that yeah I was like uh I
know how pain works yeah the body works
yeah yeah of course you should be able
to change this yeah yeah and it just
opened this and now you've had like so
many clients like specifically about and
so many like amazing Stories oh my God
from it I could just sit here and talk
about
all these empowered amazing
transformative healing birth experiences
that people had that has just oh and
even my own girls hear me talk about
this and they're so interested and I'm
like oh my gosh this is shaping them
differently than I was but I didn't even
know I was shaped I no idea that I had
been indoctrinated and shaped with this
other narrative I was it was so normal I
was unaware that it was even a thing I
didn't know about this whole other
option which is actually the more
natural option and so that was it's such
the fact that you opened this whole
experience up to me I'm so forever
grateful for oh I'm so grateful for you
because I feel like it's it's the
opportunity listen I just want to help
people I just want to help people heal
like that's my biggest thing I mean it's
just so rewarding to start with birth
to start healing mama so that baby has
this different environment to come into
so that their first entrance into this
world is like ecstatic amazing like in
such love in the body just loves and
hugs and there's not resistance they're
not meeting resistance in the first
stages of their development
like do you know a lot of trauma I deal
with goes back to birth trauma in a
adult we get back to some really
interesting things in their birth or
when they were in the womb so this is I
just feel like it is it's starting at
Ground Zero that's kind of where it
starts yes of helping people heal and I
feel like it's probably one of the most
profound things we could be doing right
now amazing well this is a great place
to stop I think it's I want to keep
going I think this is a great place and
for anyone who is interested in more of
this please check out all of her
different outlets on her website your
Instagram it's all basically mind change
it's all mine changes so um thank you so
much for being here I am so happy
um about how this went this was so
fruitful for me like I just could talk
about it forever with you so thank you
for being here okay friendship too oh
love you okay let's end the conversation
goodbye everybody
[Music]